hola
y me va a tocar empezar esta plática
justo después de que todos hubieran
tenido un break me dice tenés que
iniciar con algo fortísimo yo digo que
me rompa el saco ahí enfrente a la gente
de lo que
bueno digo empecemos con algo más
digeribles y empecemos con una pregunta
no el arte de preguntar
qué pasaría
sin un salón como éste
juntáramos a los grandes genios de la
comedia se puede poner latinos tenemos
por un lado
a roberto gómez bolaños y por el otro a
mario moreno cantinflas y si en medio de
estos dos les pongo un sócrates
creen que los tres podrían pasar
platicando sobre humor toda la noche
pues bueno sócrates no habla español así
que moriría de la plática
pero el humor que tan cotidianamente lo
vivimos que tan sabrosa mente lo
disfrutamos
a veces se nos pasa desapercibido en
todas las dimensiones que éste tiene
piense que para ludwig einstein este
eminente filósofo austríaco él creía
en más lo afirmo
cualquier tratado serio de filosofía
puede escribirse con base en chistes
a ver a ver es en serio fíjense pongamos
la prueba ahorita si quieren
[Música]
pensemos un chiste o la décimo el más
poblado que se les ocurra pero no me lo
diga
pero voy a contar un avión
estaban tres personajes estaban
nadie
ninguno y tonto cierto día tonto llama a
la policía y le dice mira ninguno se ha
caído un pozo y nadie lo está recogiendo
el señor policial pregunta señor usted
es tonto si mucho gusto
pero a ver que fueren propio de este del
lenguaje por un lado tenemos que ninguno
significa tres cosas muy diferentes es a
alguien es texto y es ficción por otro
lado tenemos tanto ninguna a nadie no
tenemos que es el otro es palabra y es
amigo
pero qué valor tienen estas palabras así
por así
cuando vemos en un mismo enunciado las
diferentes secciones o los diferentes
significados que puede tener y lo
comprometedor que puede ser darle más
valor a unos otros nos encontramos con
problemas tan profundos como las
divergencias que pueden surgir en la
ética en la biología
en los mismos procesos jurídicos piensen
por ejemplo en el concepto persona
cuando este concepto es tomado por
aparte dentro del marco jurídico dentro
del marco biológico de la ciencia o el
marco ético
piensen cuántas polarizaciones ha
generado a lo largo de la historia
y es que big einstein y los filósofos
del lenguaje pensaban precisamente que
el lenguaje en el límite a nuestro mundo
pero el mismo lenguaje nos da apertura a
interpretarlo reinterpretarlo
bueno
hasta que tenemos un chiste pero como
que todavía no nos deja muy en claro a
qué se refería vigente probemos con algo
más gráfico humor gráfico les presento
un medio bola distimo
veo que algunos tienen ya la máscara
abajo lo sacan con cangrejo ahora pero
y estoy sin mascar y acá
y me han dejado pasar
en qué momento
la moral le concede privilegios a otros
porque la norma no puede aplicarse por
igual a todos los casos es posible
construir una ética una moral universal
esta última pregunta
de tono todas las neuronas de immanuel
kant que se dio a la tarea seria de
formular un imperativo categórico
y vean que sí lo ha hecho
como es que de los chistes pasamos de
hablar de vida están acá
como es que de dos juegos de palabras
uno de humor gráfico
y el otro con conceptos muy ambiguos me
tomaba el escenario para venir les
hablar de filosofía
vamos a intentar algo de otro nivel
qué tal si probamos un blooper
ese momento
en el que vemos que un cuerpo
se eleva y por las airosas fuerzas de la
gravedad caen por favor que te mula
sabemos que le acabo de grabar la
espalda verdad
pero
a ver muchos se han reído oigan esto es
serio acabamos de ver un tipo que estuvo
muy cerca de sufrir una policontusión
bueno tal vez no porque bien la piscina
verdad pero nos hemos burlado de esto
como una situación en la que se ve dolor
corporal en la que se ve expresamente el
sufrimiento de alguien podemos reírnos
porque el juicio se suspende con la risa
en diversión
en 1900 intento trabajar qué significado
tenía la risa y la comicidad y un ensayo
muy lúcido para su época
él precisamente descubrió algo
cuando nos reímos
somos insensibles
en el momento que nos reímos todos
nuestros patrones sobre los juicios y
valores se ven modificados el humor
anula precisamente nuestra
interpretación de los hechos
y esto puede ser muy peligroso o muy
gracioso
vean para platón este problema
en el libro la repubblica en el nombre
del 388 el decía precisamente que la
risa puede ser muy peligrosa
especialmente para la juventud porque el
ánima se va agitada muy airosamente y un
anima que precisamente
está perturbada deja de pensar esto lo
puedo resumir en cuatro palabras
el problema de fondo
cuando reímos no pensamos
estamos gozando
estamos disfrutando más allá de acción
fisiológica natural que tiene la risa la
risa
precisamente pone todo nuestro córtex
frontal
anotado sobre el juicio y la liberación
de toda aquella serotonina oxitocina
nos hace sentir bien estar
pero cuál es el verdadero poder del
humor vamos a ver tengo un reto para la
imaginación a todos ustedes acá quiero
que hagan los siguientes quiero que
lleven su dedo medio y su dedo índice
tomando así las dos manos y lo lleven a
sus sienes
quiero que lo lleven a sus sienes ok muy
bien ahora quiero que todos ustedes
cierren sus ojos cuando yo haga un
chasquido van a abrirlos y van a retirar
los dedos de sus sienes muy bien cierran
sus ojos ahora quiero que visualicen
algo gracioso
todos acá muy bien levante la mano quien
se le ha ocurrido un memo
como que no está haciendo ml este asunto
no
muy bien quienes pensaron un meme a los
que han nacido probablemente
después del 2000 o alrededor del 2000
toda clase de imágenes gráficas ahora
los que no se les ha venido un meme
piensa en lo siguiente podrían con
aquello que pensaron gracioso hacer un
meme
levanten la mano
una amplia mayoría que ha pensado que
pueden hacer un meme pero en qué momento
lo gracioso
se ve tan normalizado por el uso del
meme
para la mayoría acá quizás
recuerden este tipo no me sale a la cara
cuando recordamos la historia de los
memes una década atrás la historia de
los memes es básicamente la historia si
me permite el término la momificación es
la historia de la masificación del gusto
y la masificación de lo gracioso a qué
me refiero con esto el gusto en cuanto a
aquello que parece gracioso
culturalmente se transforma según la
época pero el humor el humor que
trasciende no solamente el acto de reír
sin todas las formas que hemos creado a
lo largo de listo para crear reacciones
y yo por ejemplo ahora sacó de la manga
pero si se acaba
2 automáticamente en nuestras mentes
evocar y amos aquel icono de una
que está de una niña que precisamente
cuestiona con ironía las cosas de su
entorno sí por el otro lado yo traigo
george orwell con rebelión en la granja
vemos en él como a partir de la sátira
que también es un género del humor
cuestionamos y reutilizamos el poder y
la conducta humana
pero a ver salvar el humor no no es
solamente reirán hay otras formas de
humor el humor tiene un poder
[Música]
el poder del humor
de ustedes repasan la historia cuando
todos vamos a la clase de historia en un
momento nos hemos topado con un acápite
que tiene que ver con la historia el
imperio romano y en aquel acápite
y una frase que todo el mundo la conoce
la frase del pan y el circo
el humor convertido en una forma
instrumental se convierte en una manera
de orientar las conductas humanas con
ciertos propósitos el imperio humano
hacia aquello para poder contentar
contener cualquier clase de sublevación
pero el humor no se reduce tampoco a
este tipo de instrumentalización el
humor en todas sus formas ya sea la
sátira desea la paradoja ya sea la
ironía o el sarcasmo
todas las formas del humor
conectan
y aquí viene el verdadero poder del
humor
el humor puede conectar o puede destruir
el humor cuando es usado para conectar
además del efecto emocional nos acerca
nos humaniza
hay que tener coraje para enfrentar la
vida con humor en medio de la tragedia
piensen en chaplin todo lo que han visto
el cine mudo chaplin es el máximo icono
de alguien que hace humor frente a la
tragedia la fragilidad humana
ese esperpento del dolor y poder
asumirlo con alegría y no hablamos de un
simple efecto placebo hablamos de un
efecto de resiliencia
hablamos de poder empoderar el anima
para cambiar tu estado psíquico y
anímico y poder ver el mundo de un modo
distinto
y hay que ver cuando el bullying
destruye
cuando usamos el humor
para agredir
cuando usamos el humor para ver y
visibilizar o más bien para estigmatizar
piensan en todos los chistes en todas
las formas de humor gráficos sexistas
homofóbicas en los centristas
piensa en todas esas formas de humor que
agreden
y aquí es cuando nos llevamos al quid
del asunto
el humor no es solo existe
el humor
puede ser más que solo causar gracia
el humor también es un reflejo de la
idiosincrasia de los pueblos con el
humor tú quieres conocer a alguien
presta atención de que se ríe que temas
afines conectas con un chiste
piensen por ejemplo en los cuentos
populares piensen por ejemplo en pancho
madrigal piense en el mismo espíritu
piensen en todo lo que hace mario moreno
cantinflas piensen en todos esos iconos
que además de hacer humor
visibilizan quiénes son
el humor se vuelve si identidad
el humor refleja quiénes somos porque
hacer humor es hacernos a nosotros
mismos en el humor también podemos
educar
creo que se ha pagado esto está haciendo
una broma muy técnica cae muy bien con
el humor también educamos con el humor
sanamos cuantos sacan han visto las
películas de patch adams
cuánto no hemos conocido el efecto de la
risoterapia
cuando el humor es orientado por la
voluntad humana con fines y propósitos
muy concretos puede tener un efecto
increíble que no se reduce al mero acto
del entretenimiento al acto que
precisamente el meme hace qué pasa con
el meme a ver todos vamos un día por la
calle estamos en la casa estamos
platicando con alguien y de repente le
pasa algo a esta persona viste una
imagen capturas de una película tomas
una captura de esto inmediatamente cuál
es la siguiente idea la mente voy a
hacer un meme de esto esto me sirve para
un meme
inmediatamente asumimos la identidad del
humor con esta masificación y
automáticamente decimos voy a hacerle un
meme a pepe porque perdió su equipo
hasta los amos de cliché para llegar a
este m y me acordé de voz
y esperen están los más egocéntricos irs
en este m m me representa
el meme el humor desde donde lo tomemos
construye incluso nuestra identidad
construye lo que queremos proyectar en
el mundo si somos creadores de
contenidos si somos gente
que hacemos cosas porque todos aquí
hacemos algo y todos proyectamos algo el
humor incluso nos empodera el humor
rompe el hielo el humor rompe e incluso
la dificultad de crear cercanía con el
otro el humor nos acerca el humor
incluso hace protesta el humor critica
cuestiona
el humor hace más que solo causar risa
y ese es el poder del humor un poder que
está presente en todas las culturas en
todos los tiempos de la historia en
todos los géneros cuando piensan está
maravillada del humor
es que debemos vemos que el humor
nuestro chiste y para despedirme les
hago una invitación
brillante disfruten hagan el humor y
hagan el amor mientras se ríen y rían se
mientras se hacen el amor eso sí luego
piensen sobre lo que se ríe muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]